welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
were breaking down the ending of
chilling Adventures of Sabrina part
three throughout this video we'll be
going over everything you need to know
about the show and where things could be
heading for part 4 there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you don't want
anything potentially ruined about the
new season of the witch then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of chilling
Adventures of Sabrina part 3 okay so
part 2 had some pretty big revelations
not only was it revealed that after
Sabrina's father wasn't Edward Spellman
but actually turned out that she was
Satan's offspring the forbearer of the
apocalypse the second entry closed with
Sabrina faking a ceremony of submission
in order to trap the Dark Lord but after
this backfired
Nick ended up sacrificing himself in
order to contain him it was the ultimate
play and Sabrina had to watch as her
beloved boyfriend Nick was taken to hell
under the watchful eye of Madame Satan
the season closed for the promise
between Sabrina and her friends that
they would travel to the underworld to
get Nick back this is where Part three
picks up and the show doesn't waste any
time getting to the rescue attempt the
opening of the series really revolves
around the group doing whatever it takes
to free him from his confinement and
some of the scenes will make your toes
curl like literally I hate foot stuff
either there's lots of key events in the
season and it really engages you as you
go along for the ride
Sabrina does whatever she can to gain
entry to hell the fright Club Band
provides some awesome backing music
Madame Wardwell plays a big part after
gaining control of a life prudence and
Ambrose travel the globe in search of
father Blackwood Zelda steps up as
headmistress and there are a couple of
new characters introduced here and there
that really shake up the season whether
it's Zelda and Hilda deciding how to
inform the quote-unquote students that
they shouldn't be praying to Satan
anymore or Dorian Gray acting as a sort
of M for the group all of the actors get
some dark and twisted things to play
with people who are already invested in
the show we'll find a lot to love from
the
and this season is arguably the most
occult entry this fall it throws some
awesome nods to the Wizard of Oz the
Divine Comedy Vlad the Impaler and
within the first 15 minutes the show
sets up some big plot points that make
it arguably the best in the run for
those who don't know the Divine Comedy
is a famous Italian poem that discusses
the nine circles of hell
it chronicles the journey of Dante
through the underworld and this is
similar to the path that Sabrina and
Cole travel on in the first episode it
really allows the creative team to
switch up the environments and whether
it's the shores of sorrow the fields of
witness or a giant path of blood the
series possesses one of the most
memorable opening episodes in the show's
history upon arriving at pandemonium
they come across Madame Satan who
informs the group that in the wake of
her ascension to the throne she is
finding it difficult to gain respect no
one views her as the real ruler of the
realm and in order to get Nick back
Sabrina must assume the title of the
Queen of Hell and officially pass it
back to Madame Satan however this is
contested with the arrival of Prince
Caliban he wants to expand the circles
of hell and if he was to rule he would
pretty much mess everything up for those
who don't know
Caliban is actually a character from the
Shakespearean play The Tempest and the
character was the son of a witch who has
a lot of ambition he's an extremely
complex character and this is murdered
by his betrayal in the show he and
Sabrina even come face to face with
Pontius Pilate and reenact elements of
the crucifixion scene from the Bible
Judas also plays a big part of the show
and it's very much laced with the story
of Jesus which is murdered in Sabrina's
position as the child of Satan left with
little option Sabrina takes up the
position of the Queen in order to free
Nick and defend it from the new apparent
antagonist she also has to deal with
balancing her new role with a normal
life and seeing her having to condemn
people to hell whilst trying to make it
as a cheerleader reminds you that she
never has it easy she realizes that you
will have to transfer the soul of Satan
into a new vessel and this comes in the
form of father Blackwood I loved
watching Satan bounce back and forth
inside the character throughout the
season and it adds to the theme with
choo ality that the show possesses over
all there were also tones of identity
which are not only exemplified in Satan
but also in Sabrina
new role and Knicks lusts for pain and
pleasure with Nick free allows him in
Sabrina to rekindle their relationship
but their plans are put to a halt when a
carnival comes to town these guys
reminded me a lot of the true not from
dr. sleep and watching their rituals was
creepy as hell they travel al and make
sacrifices pray to the old gods and yeah
not good people these pagans date back
millennia before even the time of Satan
and also possess different abilities
I love the Medusa one and overall it's
just something very creepy about them
they wish to sacrifice a virgin and
luckily for them the fright Club is full
of them we still pg-13 now however the
show does actually have a subplot about
the group losing their virginity so they
can't be sacrificed and yet I wasn't
really expecting to see this in the show
similar to most of the season this group
have a double side to them a true face
that is terrifying that allows the
creative team and actors to go wild they
make for some awesome enemies and whilst
this season is plentiful when it comes
to villains
it doesn't feel overstuffed there's also
a Riverdale Easter Egg however some fans
including myself may be a bit
disappointed to learn that it's still
not a cross over now that doesn't mean
that we won't be getting one eventually
as the location definitely exists in the
Sabrina universe but this tie in with
the new murder capital of the world may
have to wait till part 4 that doesn't
mean a series isn't packed with big
moments that most people will up though
and Hilda gets engaged and starts
turning into a spider how he tries to
get closer to Rose his dad gets some
action and Nick gets caught with his
pants down I definitely feel like this
season is a lot more mature than the
prior entry and was kind of surprised to
see them diving into sex in BDSM as much
as they did this show definitely
deserves its teen rating and it gets
more and more risque the longer it goes
on what it boils down to though and what
makes Nick and Sabrina fall apart is
that deep down he knows that she loves
Harvey again this idea of duality Rises
once more with the horn head being torn
and it cements that every character has
two sides to them
what they present and what's actually
going on Harvey and Sabrina is a romance
that we've all wanted from the start and
no we initially thought they were
diverting for the show it does start to
line up with what we would expect Nick
tries to free Satan and takes a real dog
turn and we learn he's infested with a
parasite from the dark woods residue and
thus has been acting a certain way but
it is too late and he and Sabrina go on
a break the hobby Sabrina connection is
given further way when Roz is turned to
stone and she can only be freed with
loves to kiss this fails and it cements
that hobbies hard does not belong to Roz
Roz later picks up on this and yeah I
think they are teasing Sabrina and
Harvey hooking up down the line
Sabrina admits to herself that she does
love him but doesn't want to hear Roz
and yet the love triangle gets a lot
more complicated they managed to stave
off the pagans and get Roz back but
there are casualties due to Helder being
out the game Zelda is running things in
her own and she's shot by Wardwell sent
to purgatory and then murdered by
Blackwood it was a big moment in the
season however it does quickly get
undone and my big ding on the series
would be that it doesn't really feel
like it has stakes because of this a lot
of things are reversed and yeah
throughout it just kind of
retrospectively robbed these moments of
their wait a banshee comes and looks
over the property and this signals our
death and it also comes in the form of
prudence and the rest of the weird
sisters who are killed one by one
prudence is murdered by father Blackwood
and this continues his killing spree for
the finale they throw several curveballs
and it sends the series down a
quote-unquote doc timeline that I'll get
into in just a bit but there are a lot
of things that change of the dynamics of
the show madam Satan also reveals that
she's pregnant with a son and this could
assure in a new era for the Dark Lord's
Caliban trick Sabrina and she's entombed
and Harvey is captured by the pagans who
transform him pretty much everyone is
killed
Caliban becomes the ruler of Earth and
then we get a huge time jump that
chronicles his invasion of Earth in an
attempt to turn it into the tenth circle
of hell the pagans managed to push him
back and Sabrina frees herself from
death through the use of a paradox to
break it down simply there is a time
loop in which future Sabrina must come
back and free up herself it's a bit
confusing as
there would have to be one version of
Sabrina to start the loop well maybe she
was freed for in the future and time
travel back in order to start this and
yeah we just don't privy to it I don't
think they know themselves what's going
on Sabrina sees that the world is
completely destroyed
and I just want to shout out the last of
us inspiration I see you I hear you I
crap my pants the post apocalypse is a
bad place but with help from Ambrose
Sabrina is able to travel back to
Episode seven and stop Blackwood from
his killing spree
Sabrina disguised as Robin who is a
trusted member of the pagans tricks them
into sacrificing one of their own the
académie take down the group and Sabrina
goes to return to hell but a future
version stops her and breaks the time
loop trapping Caliban down there this
means that there are two versions of the
character existing at the same time one
version of Sabrina accepts her role as
Queen of hell and is adorned in
traditional wear of the realm the other
returns to Greendale and says that a
business with hell is done now there is
a specific line here that I think plays
into my theory on the finale
Lilith says that the Queen must be ready
for battle and I believe that going
ahead she may be manipulated by a father
and Lilith to launch an invasion on
earth much in the same way that Caliban
was it's been said from the start that
Sabrina will bring forth the apocalypse
and yeah this seems to be setting it up
here we did see that the invasion that
Caliban carried out was stopped by the
pagans however they have now been
defeated and it is possible that Sabrina
could end up going toe-to-toe with a
version of itself the Church of the
night changes its name to the order of
Hackett II to show that there is a
difference between their old ways and
before zelda gets a kiss there is a
mention of an even darker force on the
horizon personally I believe this
prediction is adding way to Sabrina
being at the head of the overtaking and
launching an attack on itself
Sabrina never really wanted to be the
ruler of hell and this version of
herself will likely be angered that the
other is living the life that she wished
for perhaps she will try to swap with
herself but I do think they are setting
up for a showdown between the two there
is an ocean at the end of people falling
apart from one another such as prudence
who stops speaking to Ambrose and the
Sabrina who takes at the throne
looks like she's breaking inside
everything has consequences and there
are always loose ends as Ambrose A's and
the
paradox that they have created will have
repercussions the series ends with
Blackwood and wishing his time egg on
the world and this will apparently kick
off the beginning of the end of all
things it's a huge cliffhanger to end
the show on and due to its powers we
know that it could end the Spellman's
universe and all of time sabrina man
should use the time egg in the episode
to send herself back in time and thus if
it is used in another way it could be
used to destroy all of it I actually
think that after their battle the
sabrina's will have to team up with one
another in order to put an end to it
the seasons often have several
overarching villains and this would
definitely fit in with yes thick as we
know that st. as funny stop chasing the
character after a version of her has
ascended to the throne we do know in the
vision of the future that zelda saw that
there was only one sabrina a deathbed
and even though the two versions of the
character are trying to keep separate
you would think that they would both be
there for such a big event this makes me
think that one of the Sabrina's died in
the battle with the creature and this
will sort of straighten everything out
there's a lot of ways it could go
forward but it did have a lot of fun
with this season overall a lot of it
seems inconsequential and it pretty much
goes back to the status quo by the end
bar a few changes but the write itself
was a great one and this is definitely
my favorite season so far
chilling Adventures of Sabrina keeps
getting better and that's why I get an 8
out of 10 now obviously and loved hear
your thoughts and chilling Adventures of
Sabrina part 3 so make sure you comment
below and let me know you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown app it card which is gonna be
linked at the end we go over everything
you missed and give our theories on it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more you can support
the show by subscribing to us on patreon
and if you want to come chat to us after
the video then join our discord server
in the description below or follow us on
twitter at definition whitey that's the
best way to keep up to date with
everything we do what have you spoilers
and hopefully we see over there very
soon
this is the channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you